talk to me about the kind of people
you're helping and what's happening
today
we have people from around all of
ukraine people from cities that are now
attacked by russians like km
odessa
mario so many many many other regions
are coming seeking shelter in my native
town
i'm right now i'm talking to you from
venus which is a very small town in the
rest of ukraine near borders with
european countries romania and hungary
so we have already gave a shelter to 1
000 people for the last few days
and this is like we have in our town 20
000 people so imagine 1 000 people came
just in few days
we gave the shelter them here we provide
here for them food so they now sleep in
dormitories some of them are are
provided with hotels and flats but many
of them will be soon just uh left in in
the gyms so we make we make shelters in
in schools in gyms we provide beds we
provide bath sheds we provide payloads
and we give them food so that's what we
are doing we receive a lot of support
from neighboring countries we receive a
lot of support from romania from hungary
i'm also responsible for
humanitarian assistance and help
so we are we have storages here of food
we have storages of
of many products and also some
individual protection stuff like
individual hydrogen
stuff so like soap and and payloads and
servants and stuff like that so we
collect all that and provide to to
people
yes we all that we collect all that and
we provide to the refugees
uh
all the things that they need so so far
we are good but i think that in in a few
days the situation will be worse because
even more people are coming to us
yeah andre talk to me about where people
are coming from when they get to you how
far have they traveled
what are are their plans because by the
sounds of it they are stopping in your
town to have some rest
to gather themselves and go again head
to the border where are they coming from
talk to me about their stories
okay so people are driving for 30
even 70 hours to get to this town to get
to transcription region
because of the of the lots of people
that are now traveling to this part of
the country
so they some of them they stay in in
this place they find some shelter from
them and they stay here hoping that the
war will end soon and they will be able
to come back to their homes
but many of them are traveling abroad so
now we have
queues on all our borders and some
people even sleep in the cars to get to
the europe
so that's a huge problem for us because
many of them they decide again to stay
in my native town and old towns around
here because they just can't you know
cross the border although the border
procedures are very simplified right now
still because of a huge amount of people
that are going abroad it's just
impossible to cross the border
andre
how are people because we keep talking
to people here on sky news
we want to tell ukrainian people's story
we want to inform the world about what's
happening in your country and there is a
lot of defiance from ukrainian people
but we're talking about families that
have been split up because you know for
those watching at home the men in
ukraine have to stay they have to stay
to fight and that means
that wives sisters mothers are having to
leave on their own with children for
other countries
just
just what is that like for those women
and children i can't even imagine i'm
i'm choking up just asking you the
question
you can't imagine you know like i'm 33
years old a guy who studied in the
netherlands who lived a normal life you
know in the capital of our country i
wouldn't even imagine no one would
imagine that in 21st century the war can
start the war that destroys your home
the war that destroys yourself that the
world that can kill your relatives that
just it's impossible to imagine trust me
no one can imagine
and even people in my this transcriptase
region who didn't hear the missiles they
can't imagine that there is a war just
you know six seven hundred kilometers
from here the families are split up
mothers are taking their children and
going abroad they're looking for shelter
their men are staying in ukraine they're
trying to fight they go
they go to uh to military they they want
to serve in the military they want to
fight for their home and that's the
reason why we stand for the last six
days and we we will stand even more
because this is our land we are going to
fight for every centimeter and for every
inch of our land
and we just want to make sure that our
mothers our sisters and our kids are in
the safe place and then we are going to
fight many many ukrainians are already
fighting now and that's why we need to
help all of them to make sure that you
know their backyard is secure their
families are in a secure place their
families have food and they will survive
any case
well andre you're doing an incredible
job just to reassure those who have had
to send their families away from their
home towns and cities to borders with
other countries you're doing a great job
in looking after them and make making
sure they get somewhat somewhere safe so
you know on behalf of those watching who
are effective thank you for what you're
doing and just a final question
how safe do you feel in your town at the
moment because what we are learning over
the last six days is that what we
thought would be targets by russia
everywhere is a target nowhere in
ukraine is safe how safe do you feel
right now
well this part of ukraine is safe
because it's 800 kilometers from from ku
and i would say that this is the safest
part so far part of ukraine so far
and
we don't know what will what will be in
the next few days
but i believe that we will be the last
you know piece of land
if any in any day taken by the russians
and we will fight till the end so i
believe that you know at this place
where i'm sitting right now so this will
be the place where ukrainians either
will die altogether always survive and
kill all russians and then we will stand
for our freedom
i mean russian soldiers
andre zupanin uh
mp in ukraine uh working from his
hometown to provide shelter for those
who are trying to leave ukraine as it is
under attack thank you so much for
joining us here on sky news um
thank you and we hope to speak to you
again in the future thank you